بعد خمسه اعوام من اطلاق خدمه وصفه في
السعوديه كشفت وزاره الصحه عن استمرار
الخدمه في
1417 مركزا حققت الصيدليات المجتمعيه
القريبه منها نسبه رضا مستفيدين تفوق 80%
فيما يجري العمل على اعاده جدوله تفعيل
الخدمه في 711 مركزا صحيا لم تحقق
الصيدليات المجتمعيه القريبه منها نسبه
الرضا الماموله وقد اطلقت وزاره الصحه
نظام وصفه في عام 2018 وهي خدمه الكترونيه
متطوره تهدف لرفع مستوى الخدمات الصحيه
وضمان توفر الادويه عبر ربط المستشفيات
ومراكز رعايه الصحيه الاوليه الحكوميه
بالصيدليات المجتمعيه
من الرياض ينضم الينا المتحدث باسم وزاره
الصحه الدكتور محمد العبدلي دكتور محمد
حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه اولا هل
هناك توجه لالغاء النظام او العمل بنظام
وصفته
حياك الله اخوي نايف وجميع المتابعين
والمشاهدين حاليا والمستمعين طبعا
في خدمه وصفتي الخدمه من الخدمات المتميزه
اللي وضعت لضمان تصوير العدويه
وتكون ايضا طريقه متميزه لوصول المواطنين
لها وصرفهم لها بشكل مجاني ومن المهم جدا
ايضا انها كانت تساهم في قضيه انهم يحصلون
عليها من صيدليه المجتمع القريبه منهم وفي
اي وقت يناسبهم ولذلك هي مستمره وكما
ذكرنا في اضاحات حول هذا الموضوع بانه في
اكثر من 1400 موقع ومركز هي مستمره لانه
محيطها ولله الحمد يحقق نسبه رضا
للمستفيدين ليتجاوز ال 80 ليصل الى
86% طبعا
حتى اليوم وصفتي قدمت اكثر من 55 مليون
وصفه في 172 مدينه وعبر اكثر من 3600
صيدليه مجتمعيه لكن نراجع دكتور دكتور
انتم انتم في الوزراء هل الغيتم نظام
العمل
بوصفتي في هذه الم او او ماذا لانه في
كثير من الناس يسال بعد تغريدتكم يعني عبر
حساب المتحدث الرسمي للوزاره في تويتر هل
الغيتموها هل تعيدون النظر فيها او تعودون
تعيدون التاهيل نريد ان نعرف فقط
طبعا في
14 مركز وزياده مستمرين الخطه والخطه
والمنهجيه والتوجه هو دائما الاستمرار
والتحسين فيها عندنا مواقع ثانيه رصدنا
فيها ملاحظات تتعلق بعدم الرضا كان في
مشقه على بعض المستفيدين وعدم رضا لهم
ورود صوت لهم بشكاوى لانها كانت قريبه
منهم الصيدليات المجتمعيه لذلك تم في هذه
السبعمائه وحده عشر مركز
اعاده جدوله تفعيل وصفتي فيها واعدنا
الصيدليه الداخليه هذا طبعا بشكل مؤقت
لغايه ما نطمان بان كل الحلول والام
والصيدليات المتاحه من حولها تحقق باذن
الله الرضا طيب عن موضوع الادويه في
السعوديه دائما هناك حديث عن الشح عن
الاحتكار بعض ايضا حتى صيدليات عندما تذهب
اليها لصرف وصفه مثلا او تريد طلب علاج
معين فيقابلك مثلا الصيدله او الصيدليه
الموجوده في الصيدليه
بالاجابه بانه لا يوجد هذا العلاج هناك
دواء بديل او علاج بديل لربما يكون حتى
موجود في هذه الصيدليه وايش اللي رصدتوه
بهالموضوع يا دكتور
طبعا قضيه ضمان توفر الادويه منذ سنوات
الحمد لله في المملكه عندنا شركه وطنيه
معنيه بشراء موحد للادويه وهذه تقوم بدور
فعال ومهم جدا يكفل توفر العدويه ويحدث
حقيقه نقله نوعيه في هذا في هذا المجال في
المملكه وكذلك هنالك هيئات وجهات عندنا في
المملكه تقوم بمتابعه السلوكيات متابعه
الممارسات متابعه ورصت كل ما تقوم به
الصيدليات من اجراءات سواء في التبريد
التخزين التوزيع بما يكفل انه يكون فيه
توفر دائم وحمايه
المجتمع وضمان الذي توفر ادويته لكن لو
رصدنا ونتابع دائما رصد لاي شكوى لاي
ملاحظه لاي سلوكيات او او بلاغات فورا يتم
التفاعل فيها الاجراءات المتبعه لضمان انه
ما يكون فيها ممارسه سيئه دكتور هل
ستضمرون توفر الادويه في في كل هذه
الصيدليات التابعه للمراكز الصحيه اللي
الان انت وعدتوها مؤقتا بدلا عن نظام
وصفتي
الاجراءات اللي بتتم فيها هو عوده
الصيدليه بقوائم الادويه المعتمده بحد
نطاق هذه الخدمات من المراكز ونتابع واي
ملاحظه بنرصدها بانه دواء غير متوفر فورا
للتدخل وبنقوم بمعالجه ذلك اشكرك جزيلا
شكرا من الرياض المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه
دكتور محمد العبد